an awkward smile this morning for the
cameras Kevin Spacey is used to the
spotlight but will not be welcoming this
coverage today the world learned more
about the sex crimes he's accused of as
his criminal trial got underway
prosecutors have described him as a
sexual bully who used his status as a
Hollywood star to make others feel
powerless he denies all the allegations
the prosecution say Kevin Spacey's
preferred method of assault was to grab
other men in the crotch aggressively for
his own personal sexual gratification
but perhaps one of the most distressing
accounts we heard today was that of a
man who would have been in his early
twenties at the time an aspiring actor
who'd agreed to a drink with Spacey he
thought to discuss his career that drink
ended at space's accommodation the man
said that he fell asleep or passed out
and woke up hours later to find Kevin
Spacey performing an unwanted sexual act
on him
Spacey became artistic director at
London's Old Vic theater in the early
2000s and spent time living in the UK
his alleged crimes took place in the
capital and gloucestershire his defense
Barrister Patrick Gibbs Casey advised
the jury to question the accusations
what has been reimagined with a Sinister
spin he asked adding you will hear some
truths some half truths some deliberate
exaggerations and many damned lies
starting next week his accusers will get
their chance to tell their stories in
court some say the actor initially made
them Starstruck all of them say he
abused his Celebrity Status to try and
get what he wanted his trial is expected
to last around four weeks Becky Cottrell
Sky News Southern Crown Court